New Gemini canvas update is insane.
Google just dropped something that
changes everything. I'm talking about
the new Gemini canvas update. This thing
turns Google search into a full
workspace. No extra apps, no signups.
And I'm going to show you exactly how it
works right now. So, Google just rolled
out this update called Canvas in AI
mode. And honestly, when I first saw it,
I thought, "Okay, cool. Another AI
thing." But then I actually used it and
it blew my mind because this is not just
a chatbot anymore. This is a workspace
inside Google search. You can build
stuff, real stuff, dashboards, apps,
documents, code, all from a simple
prompt. Now, let me break down what this
actually is. So, you know how normally
you go to Google, you type something in,
and you get a list of links. That's the
old way. With AI mode, Google already
started giving you AI answers right at
the top. But now with Canvas, it goes
way further. You can open up a side
panel and inside that panel, you can
create things, not just read things,
create them. Here is how you use it. You
go to Google search, you click on AI
mode. Then you see a little plus button
in the chat. You tap that. You pick
Canvas. And then you just tell it what
you want. That's it. That simple. Like
you could say, "Build me a project
tracker or write me a blog post or
create a study planner." And it just
does it right there inside Google
search. Now, here is where it gets
really wild. And this is the part most
people are going to miss. Hey, if we
haven't met already, I'm the digital
avatar of Julian Goldie, CEO of Goldie
Agency. Whilst he's helping clients get
more leads and customers, I'm here to
help you get the latest AI updates.
Julian Goldie reads every comment, so
make sure you comment below. Okay, so
back to why this update is such a big
deal. Canvas doesn't just write plain
text. It builds interactive things like
actual working dashboards, actual
working tools. You can ask it to make a
habit tracker, a scholarship tracker,
and it pulls in real-time information
from the web to make it accurate. It
uses Google's knowledge graph. So, the
data is fresh, the data is real. And the
coding part, oh man, this is the part
that got me. You can now ask Canvas to
write code for you. And not just write
it, you can see the code, you can edit
the code, you can refine it, you can
test it, all inside Google search. You
don't need to open a code editor. You
don't need to install anything. You just
ask for it and it builds it. Let me give
you some examples so you can see how
powerful this is. Say you are a student.
You could type in create me a weekly
study planner with all my subjects,
deadlines, and a progress tracker. And
canvas will build that for you with
sections with structure ready to use. Or
say you run a business, you could type
in build me a task management dashboard
with a to-do list and deadline tracker
and boom, it makes it right there. Or
say you are a content creator, you could
type in, "Draft me a 1500word blog post
about AI tools for SEO with an intro,
features section, examples, and
conclusion." And it writes the whole
thing structured, organized, and then
you can refine it with follow-up
messages like you can say, "Make the
intro more punchy or add more examples
in section 3." And it updates it just
like that. Now this is the thing that
makes Canvas different from other AI
tools. It is built into Google search.
So it has access to everything Google
knows. Every website, every piece of
data, every fact. It pulls from real
search results. So when it builds you
something, it is not just making stuff
up. It is using real information from
the web. And here's the kicker. You
don't need a subscription. You don't
need to sign up for anything new. If you
are in the US and you use Google search
in English, you already have it. It is
just there waiting for you to use it.
Now, let me show you some prolevel
prompts you can use right away because
the quality of what Canvas gives you
depends on how good your prompt is. So,
here are some prompts that work really
well. First one, create a weekly
productivity dashboard with tasks,
deadlines, and code to track progress.
Include charts and an option to export
to CSV. That one is fire. It gives you a
full working dashboard. Second one,
draft a 1500word article on AI canvas
use cases with sections for intro
features, examples, and conclusion. That
gives you a full structured article you
can edit and publish. And third one,
build me an interactive habit tracker
that lets me check off daily habits and
see my streak. That one is perfect if
you want to build a little tool for
yourself. Now, by the way, if you want
to learn how to use AI tools like Gemini
Canvas to actually grow your business
and get more customers, you need to
check out the AI profit boardroom. This
is where we go deep on AI automation and
show you exactly how to use tools like
this to scale. Whether you are using
Gemini canvas to build dashboards for
your clients or to speed up your content
creation, the AI profit boardroom is
where you get the full playbook link is
in the description. Okay, so let me keep
going because there is more you need to
know about this update. One thing I
really like about canvas is the
follow-up chat feature. So you don't
just get one output and that's it. You
can keep talking to it. You can say
actually change the color scheme or add
another section or make the code do this
instead. And it updates everything in
real time is like having a conversation
with a designer and a developer at the
same time. And think about what this
means for the future. Right now it is
documents, dashboards and code. But
where do you think this is going? Google
is basically turning search into an
operating system. A place where you
don't just find information, you build
with it, you create with it, you work
inside of it. Now, let me give you some
tips to get the best results from
Canvas. Tip number one, be specific with
your prompts. Don't just say, "Make me a
dashboard." Say, "Make me a dashboard
that tracks these five things with these
columns and this layout." The more
specific you are, the better the output.
Tip number two, use follow-up prompts.
Don't settle for the first thing it
gives you. Refine it. Ask it to improve.
Ask it to change things. The magic is in
the iteration. Tip number three, ask
canvas to show you the code even if you
are not a coder because seeing the code
helps you understand what it built and
you can copy that code and use it
somewhere else if you want. Tip number
four, think of canvas as a prototyping
tool. You can use it to quickly test
ideas, build a rough version of
something, see if it works, and then
take it from there. It is the fastest
way to go from idea to prototype that I
have ever seen. Now, a few things to
keep in mind. Right now,
canvas in AI mode is only available in
the US and only in English. So, if you
are outside the US, you might have to
wait a bit. But knowing Google, this is
going to roll out everywhere soon. Also,
it works on both desktop and mobile. So,
you can use it from your phone, which is
pretty wild when you think about it.
Building dashboards and writing code
from your phone. This update is honestly
one of the biggest things Google has
done with AI in search because it
changes what search is. It is not just
an answer engine anymore. It is a
workspace, a creation tool, a coding
environment all in one place and it is
free and it is available right now. So
here's what I want you to do. Go to
Google search right now. Click AI mode.
Hit that plus button. Open canvas and
build something. Anything, a planner, a
tracker, a blog post, a piece of code.
Just try it and then come back here and
tell me what you built. Julian reads
every single comment. So, drop your
results below. I want to see what you
come up with. And if you want the full
process, SOPs, and over a 100 AI use
cases just like this one, join the AI
profit boardroom. We show you step by
step how to use AI tools like Gemini
Canvas to automate your workflow, serve
your clients better, and scale your
business faster. This is the best
community for anyone serious about using
AI the smart way. Link is in the
description. And if you want even more
free resources, join the AI success lab.
It is our free AI community. Links are
in the comments and description. You
will get all the video notes from there,
plus access to our community of 38,000
members who are crushing it with AI.
Make sure you like this video,
subscribe, and hit that notification
bell so you never miss an update like
this one. I will see you in the next